so playing first
representing team rosen
karen boyd no
oh no my queen
oh yes
yes and representing team ben
is ethan yay go ethan
take her down
okay
all right we got d4 a shocking no
d4 d5 bishop oh we have the we have the
thing actually you have the thing yeah
but uh
let me try and keep up here
karen's white and she's playing on
eric's team
oh no my queen oh yes my karen
no oh man this is hard to keep up
uh can you switch back to this one yes
okay
but then i agree but but i haven't i
have to save this if you have to do that
yeah i guess i can do okay
if you want to commentate on this
position yeah i can do that while you're
doing it yeah it's sweet you know what
you're doing i know what i'm doing all
right
so karen played the london and eric and
i almost fell out of our chairs we've
never seen such uh well actually no
that's all she ever plays
i told eric it would be a london's he
just made all these moves before they
even showed up
that's the chessboard
yeah no that's chat box where's
chessboard go down
there you go oh wait go down again
there it is chessboard nice yeah
you don't want chess.com you don't want
that we want this right yeah whatever
that is
there you go
did you do it no
i'll make a new source
all right so karen castle with her queen
good good
yay thanks for the rate eric you're
welcome
okay
all right so far both players stand
badly
black has nice control of the center
white solid
yeah you did good thank you
oh it's a breakthrough or is it
okay i think that's beautiful right okay
did you could you yeah i have to have to
do this
yeah yes
okay okay let's see if it's on the
stream i i miss half the game that's
okay we're in the middle game
yeah that looks like it's working
but your head is like under the board
i'll move my hand closer to your head
that's right yeah okay
all right so let's do some analysis of
this game so the players can hear us
um what happened to karen's london
bishop uh got traded for the bishop on
d6 oh
yeah this looks like a london
like gradually crumbling
no no it looks good looks good
it's solid
yeah obviously black black's clearly
slightly better
but actually it's it's it's going to be
like an equal ending well slightly
better gonna have black though
that's true yeah after
pawn takes pawn do you think the times
are accurate on the clock
maybe we don't have the times on the
stream we don't see the time no okay
close enough but karen has a lot of time
yeah it's close on time both players are
playing it's three two by the way three
minute with a two second increment
yeah we're in the room karen's playing
we can see her
if only they were watching your stream
yeah they can hear us
yeah
if you guys can't hear us then wave or
something yeah yeah
this is an irl sub battle as that's
correct
karen karen is my sub and my mod
and your wife and on your team
yeah that's right
so each three
i like the position very like karpovian
play h3 for both players
making
making luft
this is like karpov versus putin you're
saying
yeah but even more exciting even more
exciting yeah right yeah
it's like off anderson versus liko
i feel like all three results are
possible here all three results will
happen anyone can blunder their queen at
any time oh no my queen already
blundered my queen before the sub battle
started
you'll get her back eventually maybe
this is too much chess content they said
on on my stream oh
oh you have a chat yeah i'm just voting
for people in the future yeah yeah the
chat is uh discussing the game except
they're not discussing it
they're they're overwhelmed and they're
underwhelmed
let's see 94's are really nice i have
900 people watching so we are interested
to all 900 people yeah
nice yeah word to your mother's
also your mother
all right so still black is clearly
slightly better
check
will she find the only move
the answers fries
okay so we're on multiple platforms
between is that good
no she played king h2 no
oh no my knight
throwing the game so that eric's team
will lose
no it's just giving her opponent a false
sense of confidence that's also true
oh
the video is a little bit choppy here
but just a little choppy oh look at that
pin it's a nice pin that pin is it's
it's it's too late for let's see we have
the time too 96.
defending the bishop terrible
and now it's all about it looks like
team feingold this match but not team
boyd
that's true
yeah it was all about activating the
king but it's probably not going to help
light and yeah why didn't you need to
play f1 that was important not f1 was a
key defensive move
but that king is active
if it can win the b6 pawn
while the moves just came in yeah
yeah king b4 is now a threat but g4 okay
going for the pawn storm
and karen
doing caring things
what are you carrying one the beep on
what are we in vegas yeah but uh
truth hurts
yeah that's
you know she just has to win all of the
remaining pawns go karen king b4 hey
this still has the wrong names of the
people this has the board three
yeah we might have to crop that yeah
yeah these are these are different
people
karen has white
okay so stalemate is inevitable it'll be
a tight match
i mean
karen this is your title
wrestle for the belt
i don't know if i could beat you in arm
wrestling that's why i wanted to do it i
could let you win i feel like your
muscles are larger than mine no i just
have more of me than you that's true
probably got you by about 90 pounds
probably okay made in four one two three
four stalemate in three
are we gonna see queen d3 checkmates no
maybe i think we are wait a minute look
at that
ethan with his patterns yeah gg
blue i mean yay feingold okay okay i
lost the first game oh no my karen hey
okay so karen lost the first game so
team feingold is ahead
she did as i told her
there's actually a serious belt here
there's a world heavyweight championship
out that we're playing our teams are
fighting for each each player plays two
games one with white one with black they
switch now they're gonna switch chairs
and then that's there's four boards so
it's gonna be eight games total and then
time control is three minute with the
two second increments
we have the first scorer uh 1-0 for team
feingold
i'm sad so what do you think of that
game looks like it was like white was
slightly worse the whole game when she
bonded a piece yeah what happened in the
opening like it was some you saw the
london but
black got an e5 they go ahead
yeah
ethan knew what he was doing earlier
like karen has to play like an earlier
e4 or knight e5 yeah i always tell her
to play knight yeah you should teach her
you should teach her no she's been
strong
are we ready for game two
game two is starting shortly also it
already started there might be some
delay okay so it should pop up
um if you open the site again
yeah i have to open the site it's
probably
okay now what refresh refresh
so we have a
semi slot
another very solid opening do you teach
this to karen as well
no i don't teach anything to karen she
has her own teachers how come it's not
popping up on my stream
um yeah fix it okay fix it fix it fix it
fix it fix it fix it debugging look here
but she's played in early c6
oh no she played this log
and then she played the semi slog oh
interesting oh yeah you probably have to
change the
url
for the chessboard
maybe on the browser
does that make sense to you what's going
on
yes okay
yeah you fixed it probably
uh
all right still still a solid semi slav
nope karen got c5 in go karen
i'm going to add the window capture
okay new
there we go
and now
we have
yeah i couldn't get rid of the names
keep the time somehow
too complicated too complicated all
right we can always read off the time
all right we have the trades of the d
and the c pawns it's it's the most equal
of positions now her opponent
ethan played a rook to the c file karen
hid her queen oh no my queen
oh yes my queen oh yes
yeah you played two games one with white
because she played queen c7 rook c1
queen b
yeah usually you want your queen on b8
with the rook already developed to c8 i
don't want to hear any excuses that's
okay yeah we got a sub
yeah every every every match has two
games they switch colors and there's
four matches this is match one this is
game two
confusing the audience
all right this is like the last game
it's almost completely equal but
somebody's very slightly better
very slightly oh this is what happens
when two solid players like collide
like one you mean they ran into each
other someone's gonna get hurt
eventually
especially with like all of them karen
lost the first game karen has black this
game
knight c6 is somewhat of a fork
but now just a lot of things getting
traded what do you want what happened
why is the rook on c acon
it just disappeared it just disappeared
off the board should we look at a slow
motion replay
no i don't think she lost her rook oh
she's actually oh she's actually she's
down the exchange always sexy knights
are more powerful than blitz always sack
the exchange
like two nights two nights
all right go team feingold i mean karen
that's a dangerous bishop on d2
yeah karen stopped the big threats
falling into more threats but he can't
play the winning threat because never do
that
never play rook c8 right but no next oh
never play oh
can't do it don't don't say it too
loudly no i would never do that
although i don't trouble sue
i don't troubleshoot that's although if
we play the move that should never be
mentioned there is uh this move queen d6
yeah which is
surprisingly tricky
yeah
but i think karen is realizing the
danger there's uh
some legal news
oh no oh no your team
oh no one of the knights or both of the
knights
that's good karen did this instructed
perfect
it was a good game up until
exactly the exchange
yeah
what to do
but never resign
that's right and she never will is this
what you teach her
i don't i don't think sure i'm not she
has that i say i say
never give up well there's a rule you
should never resign when you have a
knight
remember
remember jim valvano the guy who had
cancer and he said never give up never
give up
no no he died oh yeah
this is 20 years ago
he was a famous basketball coach
okay so queen the queen is now attacking
the rug maybe he'll play rook eight
we'll probably get some more active yeah
h3 gets some lift
h3 equals gear
maybe he'll play queen d4 if they kick
after queen takes rookie sm8 getting the
knights defending queen d4 rookie okay
rook c1
professional move
too professional if you ask me i didn't
even see rick it was a blunder i thought
you were just suggesting a good move oh
no
oh no black was black had some threats
yeah that was two threats one for each
of you
it's gonna be hard to have threats now
queen d8 setting up for the next game
defending the back rank
preventing queen eight
man the crowd's pretty quiet that's good
they listened
it's intense
so karen has 53 seconds left
ethan's still
hovering around in the 22.
oh the game ended abruptly karen won
it's past ethan's bedtime he had to go
to bed
oh snap
sorry ethan tough break
okay now that there's luft
yeah neither and a queen trade and
ethan's not as bad as he plays right
showing what's good
yeah we're going to be down somebody
said go cameron 0-2
is this ethan from atlanta there's
ethan's all over the world
hey we got raided by who
online we're doing an in-person
sub-battle
and we're in las vegas
and
this is game two and karen has black she
lost game one this game doesn't look
much better
what happened with the moves
white shouldn't be thinking forever
right
it's true i think there's some delay but
maybe he fought forever and played a3
very suspicious very safe very safe
thanks for giving her a shout out thanks
for the raid
yeah eric has video of them actually
playing the physical players
we're gonna
we're gonna interpose a video in
post-production
um
yeah very intense matchup here
and both players like falling like
assuming the time is correct ethan has
10 seconds left yeah but let's not
assume the time is correct because this
probably isn't
i'm getting more of your face in
oh yes my face yes
your face
your face
i haven't heard that one you never heard
that song no i've heard of my face the
first time ever i saw your face you
don't know that song no
what i mean like rings about like 1973
that was important i don't want to hear
any excuses
i heard the bird is the word the okay
there you go that's that's from
1960 i think
i thought that was just funny
i thought that was just from family guy
no that's a real song it's a real song
that's an actual that
yeah if the time is right i'm looking
good but i don't think the time is right
but if the time is looking good
i mean
you're looking good based on material
the material is not so good for me are
we going to see a dirty flag i hope so
or still needs
a gallbladder needs to do is sack the
rest of the pawns and
not going to happen
still theory
there's two second increment right
that's not good
that's not good at all no i mean that's
good for you go karen
go karen
hey activate that king
wait we're we're two moves away from
stalemates
even if you run the king even after even
after white moves a lot of time white's
clock is still going
uh
yeah there's some delay with the time
oh no
there's some disputes
what happened
oh did karen flag
no i think your guy flagged i think it
was a draw
td there's like there's like 50 people
watching disgusting
come on cd what happened
insufficient whose flag is down ethan
it appears ethan's flag is down so it's
a draw the game ended in a draw
oh no oh no your team oh wait no my team
go karen wait what happened there his
time ran out yay dirty flag okay
a perfect game karen drew that game
a solid draw with black so next will be
uh smakistan against nordvik
okay so yeah
so nordvik is i guess the one that you
call a doofus
you started it
no you you started a few weeks ago on
your stream oh you called him the dojo
yeah i thought him it was him i think so
you drew
yeah come say hi on the stream come say
hi
it's karen are we ready to start guys
good job
we don't know yet we're proud of you is
he ready to start yesterday yes we are
it was totally
unfair hey he's rated 2 000 your guy on
board four against karen wait really
yeah that's what she said he's 2 000
right he's 2 000 yeah well he was a
last-minute feeling he he was playing
pretty well yeah
i think we just should stand
blocking there was no behind
blocking
i don't know
okay
welcome to round two
oh no round two
is round three right
hey you fixed it maybe yes okay that was
quick that was quicker i'm learning
you're getting better i'm becoming more
powerful yes so we haven't learned anna
no which guy's my guy your guy i don't
even know your guy's playing black okay
my guy's playing white
wait my guy's playing jack can you play
bishop g4 that's my guy that's your guy
oh no it's a e6 he changed his mind oh
the fake house yeah that was good i
almost played one move but play another
movie yeah that was tricky okay so my
guy has black my guys nordvig nordvik
okay lord vic yes with the k with a c
lord vic with a c yeah
so it's like nordic with an action
so we want to mention the first match
was completely unfair karen was playing
a guy rated 2 000.
so and what's karen's rating uh 13 20.
yeah okay so we got a half out of two
that's pretty good i mean
that's good for for my team yeah yeah
oh there is some skewer
but that's okay
so we're gonna have a sharp game
opposites like castling yeah my team's
not looking good this game
i mean i knew it was a difference before
i met him wow
that's pretty good
and i was right so yeah so nordvik
sometimes streams on the chess dojo
channel
um he's one of like the the uh not the
senseis but those are all doofuses yeah
okay
yeah i was wondering
but uh he's wrapping the dojo merch
and now wrapping the ben feingold team
go my team
i mean i keep rooting against my team i
don't know it's not good that's okay
it's sometimes hard to be loyal i can't
believe my team's ahead
all right so what's black doing is he
playing bad on purpose i think he's
like there hasn't been any obvious
blunders oh okay you said bishop h4 was
winning the bishop h4 was always sack
the exchange a missed opportunity
and i i'm liking the way smakistan is
like smacking the pawn smacking him down
there yeah
smack that knight on d4
[Music]
man every move is good for wyatt like
that one
it's a nice move
how does block defend d4 that's how
you can't expect my people you can't
expect my team to know the on persona
roll
that's asking too much
well that's looking good for you tying
up the match
yeah a win in this game will uh will
make it one and a half off
and i think we've decided the tiebreaker
is arm wrestling so okay you're like
younger than me i might die
yeah i don't want to injure you too
solid since i have the weight advantage
i'll let you do left hand or right hand
whichever you prefer can i do both
left and right versus my my hand maybe
okay maybe
we'll see how well we'll see if i can
win easily or not yeah
we have to hope that it's not a tie now
rosen kills feingold at match and
details at 11. oh dear
okay so no black is gamuting some pawns
but opening some vials
it says ben has dead strength
i do have two kids
and one of my kids is older than you
right you have two kids yeah i have a 20
year old i think you had more
more no those are those are karen's kids
karen has two kids and i have two kids
but they're not our kids i see yeah i
thought you were surprised i had two
instead of one you thought i had more
than two
yeah that's what she said i thought you
had more than two yeah no i have a 20
year old and spencer's birthday was
three days ago so he's 31. what are you
28 or something i'm 28 yeah
i'm like half your age
no i'm 52. uh you're halfway i used to
be you're half karen's age okay
man like karen did great for for your
team
i mean she true
yeah that's actually really over
performing oh look at this look at this
this knight is pinned look at this but
look at that oh look at that oh look at
that move yeah that was a good move i
was expecting 97 egg no good moves stop
that
you don't see my team playing good moves
that's so nice
okay white with a significant time
advantage
and assume the clocks are correct based
on the previous game
whoa what's happening what world am i in
okay bad moves are allowed as well
what's going on here
but that's actually a fascinating i
don't even understand everything's
hanging now
yeah what
can i get a what what
the queen is hanging both knights are
hanging both bishops are hanging yeah
agreed
i'm too old for this
you're especially too old for this
knight takes e7 is the funniest move
yeah making all the queens even more
hanging all the king's horses and so
forth
i think it's bad
although maybe it's good bad for who for
whom
for everyone yeah
wait why is black thinking here
did he forget why he did that
we're catching up on time
king on d7 is nice without a minute for
each player
team rosen is white team feingold black
no
oh no my team
confusing the audience
that's the type of move that's like
super mystery it's a mysterious rook
move
now there's three attackers against the
knights man but white white house has an
f5 look white has a good move here
that was the ring f7 was played g7 was
good too
oh i think this move is better
this move like ends the game
yeah too many good moves from white
oh no my king
the king escapes there you go safe
activate that king in the end game
and now
black is almost checkmating in one move
almost but not quite
black has to whip up a quick attack here
very quick
and just keep developing the king
king d5 there we go
hey we think alike
activate the kick yeah
okay less than 10 seconds for black
plays rook f8 yeah that's what i thought
was the right move okay that's the best
practical try
whoa king f5
that is not as good as taking the free
rook yeah
and now everything is either players saw
vicious move backwards
oh black and threatened made in one
that's right
yes
whose turn is it okay explosive move
coming
c4 no queen g4
main one is still being threatened
though
i have to boo the players because
they're terrible play
no
oh no my team
oh yes my team thanks for the sub score
is now tied one and a half one and a
half it's one and a half one and a half
let's go
we're reaching the halfway point
that's correct after this match there
will be two more matches
yeah you can start two games
and you may begin
i mean yay
oh no my dgt it still says ggt
i blame society
i'll i'll take the blame okay
i am society you've done nothing
okay i fixed it fix it so what opening
was this
this is a uh wait a minute oh this is
your opening this is my opinion i had a
guy come to my house
yeah did they win in eight moves no they
won in like 40 movies it was crazy
that was a crazy game okay so
this is a really important
line to know for black
but does smakistan know it is it really
important to know
uh it's really important okay because a
lot of grand masters play this line yeah
yes
this one will be nice yes
oh bishop f2 is that what you would have
played uh
yes wow yeah bishop f2 94 and there's a
funny line where the king goes to f3 or
e3
and then ends up taking the knight
and and then if it was the what's that
game were you win king of the hill king
of the hill yeah
yeah we saw that kind of in the previous
game but much later on
but already like before move 10 white's
king can get to the center
so my guys white this game
that's not good for me so nordvik
looks like he retreated to g always
retreat
following and now the game window the
game will be in a perpetual first and
black black is able to force a draw here
i've had this position myself at least
like inside a dozen times
in in like blitz and bullets yeah did
you did you ever not force the draw and
you decided to win no very often i'll
all try to play for a win yeah how's
that work because usually white takes a
ton of time to get to this position
that's right yes and then they're just
already about to flag
i've had this uh against multiple gm's
too
against gm's i'll usually take a draw
though
thanks for whatever that noise was
hooray
yeah it was it was it was a noise nice
i do have ben's chat open shout out to
yeah thanks for the thanksgiving stephen
gray
steven gray gifting five oh thanks for
the five gift subs
wow bishop d7
playing for a win but oh no the knight
bishop d7 is probably not the right way
to play for a win well bishop d7 yeah
it's not the best it prepares castle
[Music]
it prepares to be done two pieces that's
the price a little bit
but the more pieces you lose the less
pieces you have to blunder three legal
moves and two of them are terrible
g3
are we playing touch move
no
no
no it's a clock move
okay it's move 12 and white still has
only one thing developed
[Laughter]
what else
what you're going to say was move 12 of
my guys down two pieces but you you
tried to spin it the right way
like guys about spinning in positive
ways yeah okay rookie one
he's gotta you got an extra pawn for the
pieces
safer king yeah
not much safer but safer
got the pawn swarm rolling yeah
bishop f4 good move
oh no the guy's queen
so the queen has some choices
it moved looks like to c5
with check okay attacking the king
attacking an undefended pawn on c2 wow
good fork
could have played queen f2 defending the
check and the pawn but
instead
about to lose a pawn
now black can choose between taking the
pawn
or continuing the pawn five
ah he took the important pawn
i got two pawns for two pieces getting
closer
that's true about to win the third pawn
maybe
oh no my guy's time advantage
yeah time is relatively level about a
minute 15 a piece
white still has pieces to develop
and black has almost everything
developed
somebody said go karen agreed
yeah carrying bishop d2 that's what i
would say
oh wait a minute bishop d2 what i meant
was i
i'm gonna get a lobotomy tomorrow so i
forgot the guy played bishop d2
that's not sure if i understand this
yeah i won't remember
uh okay here we go g5 now we're talking
let's get some g5 i wish my guy was down
two pieces for nothing
where's my g5 e modes i'm a g5 email i
have a g5 e mode
man you must be an og
we are in las vegas at the national open
in the playing room
it's a real live stream
oh no my stream i'm really struggling
with these emotes
i don't know who's the favorite this
game
i think this is a good matchup yeah like
both games have been pretty exciting
queen f1 always play queen f1 i think
white should play more passively the
last few moves
is it possible
i mean g3 king g1
yeah there we go
this is already waiting for black
are we going to see it i don't think so
oh gh
okay
this is a fascinating game
all three results will happen
it's three pawns for two pieces
yup i knew he'd block his c3 yeah
it's just another sacrifice whoa
queen b6
sacking the exchange but getting rid of
white's most dangerous bishops if we
cared about this match we'd really be
upset now both of us we would be a
little bit upset
but i literally don't care i don't care
i literally i don't care i don't care
that's okay it's okay
all right go my team
pages if the clocks are right you guys
not doing so well
wait my guy yeah my guy is
below 10 seconds yeah also time
situation is suspicious
whoa rook g7 x-clam hanging both rocks
confusing the point yeah
what a move
rook d7 always sack the exchange
okay moves are flying by uh-huh and
they're all they're gonna break the dgt
board probably we have uh
oh dear we we have the full video i
think they broke the dgt board's broken
because of all the terrible moves yeah
we have to
this feed
um
so both sides resign simultaneously
somehow black's queen vanished from the
board nice
does what it's like black has an h-pawn
white has a queen bishop
looks like queen bishop knight versus
king and rook
am i guys playing faster and the crowd
is about to go wild
but you guys know
yay
it's falling you guys broke the ggt
board it stopped showing the game
it couldn't believe what you guys were
doing
pieces flew everywhere
the decision was changed to practice
protect the spectators
the cap score was 0.9 for white 0.8 for
black
okay so team ben takes the lead
[Music]
uh the next match-up
or two
uh plain white this game so white won
the game eventually black lost all of
his pieces and his time ran out and
white was stacking papers
two and a half one and a half for gun go
ben ross the boss playing white against
brigham
brigham go bring him that's my guy right
that's your guy yeah he's always he's
always showing me his games he's uh
yeah he's been a long time subscriber to
me as well so
isn't your guy better than my guy
uh
i don't know actually
they're both kind of mysterious players
because they play a lot online i'm
mysterious
and have a brief intermission to fix the
dgt board yeah we might have to do some
reparations after that last game yeah
and rosa boss this is like his face
reveal because he he does stream on
twitch yeah but he doesn't show his face
so
that way you get more views this this
way yeah
you make sure that uh
go carry on you exist it's karen
okay and we're ready to go
that's what you think
okay it's working good it's working
almost good yeah
he says it's working now hey i got the
moves it's a stafford
it's another stafford oh ross is like
really booked up but brigham probably
knows what he's doing too
oh this is going to be exciting look
brigham's not young they're following
mainline opening theory all right
did you know there's a variation in the
stafford
named the rossa boss variation i did not
know that it's about to happen
wait which color is my guy your guy is
playing white yeah so my guys are always
no wait wait wait wait wait wait no my
guy's playing white
boss is white he's playing against his
own line he's playing so the roster boss
variation is bishop d7 which wasn't
played
oh that's kind of funny so bishop b6 was
played
and ross has studied this opening
probably more than me
that's a good use of time it's a
brilliant use of time yeah
and after yeah after each three this guy
said can we say the players ratings when
they start playing bad
uh they're both around like 15 to 16 to
1700 yeah around there yeah give or take
a few hundred points there you go right
i hope that's precise enough so my guy's
black right
yeah you guys i can see that he's black
he's also red like you you're he's
matching him just like yeah and your
guys wearing black like you yeah yeah
okay color coordinating red and black
team
so white wins a pawn
another black's not down two pieces so
blacks should be pretty happy
yeah pawns are in pieces
unfortunately
you know when i play this different on
my stream i'm just down two or three
puns right away and i don't care it's
not a great opening objectively you know
i figure if i'm down two or three pawns
that's good but yeah you get some open
vials yeah there we go black has three
extra half open vials now
and white has not lost a single point
i've never heard that in commentary
black has three extra half open files
that's a good way it's a nice form of
compensation that's right
but white can create like um
white's
white six moves away from connect eight
that's correct f4 g4 h4
must have heard you he
i thought he was speaking quietly enough
maybe not
i guess the elo
let's see how many viewers i have
are we still on chess tv yeah fifteen
hundred views hey let's go hello hey we
got fifteen hundred viewers on twitch
so play good guys don't be too nervous
no i'm just kidding
play your usual game
yay thanks for whatever happened yeah
the sub
knight g8 okay setting up setting up for
the next game perfect
now this guy plays like me he's got a
lot of material he hasn't knight g8
half open files black has to figure out
how to uncastle now that's right
though it was the only move for the
night that doesn't blunder the night
good analysis thanks
unleashing the rook
unleashing the latent potential oh
that's that ruins the connect eight
well it's just aiming to get connect
eight on the fifth fifth rank unlikely
less than 50 chance
especially after g6
now the board isn't broke that's the oh
wait a minute yeah how come my board
stopped working
my board stopped working but yours
didn't mine's working
[Music]
but it works and then it's not okay
you fixed it by doing nothing the magic
touch good i just
thanks for telling us the board broke
okay so the trail on g6 white's lost
their first pawn of the game
this game is going to come down to who
wants it more
who do you think wants it more uh so far
neither player wants it more
where to put the bishop wow
not moving the bishop but
counter-attacking yay connect four
knack four is nice
still theory
so this is the best black can do in the
stanford anyway right what's wrong with
this
so there's an even better line which
maybe we'll see played in the next game
yeah next year we can have a stafford
themed uh we should do like a thematic
tour yeah i guess some kind of spot
because you're the stanford experts it's
unfair i mean i could teach you my ways
yeah
queen g5
yeah the problem for white is the king
is still in the center
and
things are not developed
but
white's still up a lot of pawns
g4 confusing the streamer g4
that's what you would have played
i'm not even sure what he should play
in that position bishop e2
then queen g3
yeah yeah come on man yeah
it might be better than what he did
that's true
this isn't good this is good for black
how could that happen
it is
also your guy's not doing
no ross has enough time he does
i think
does he
king d2 okay
running to the queen side
this game turned on a dime i guess black
wanted it more
i think it's still anyone's game
i always think that
even when karen just had a king i
thought she might win
that's true yeah karen's a miracle ross
told me he is an expert at the stafford
yeah but after the staffer the middle
game comes and then you have to be an
expert on that too yeah it's
unfortunate come on cube cube
let's go q it's a pawn cube yes i'm so
happy yeah but i'm kind of sad for my
it's connected to four against the cube
all right yeah we need four 50 50.
did he he'll they're doing whatever they
want
wait a minute who's getting mated here
white's about to lose a pawn on h3 no
they don't have a pass to h-pawn i have
to give a spike check
two legal moves
what to do
if the time is right that's not good
you got you got one wait let's have one
second
we have five seconds
okay moves are coming in very quickly
and the board is waiting to catch up
mm-hmm
wow
the king got to be three yeah but he
actually didn't snap that mate that's
true
so no one's getting mated instantly
that's not good for you you guys six
seconds and no pieces but your guy has
19 seconds yeah but he has pieces and
yeah but no pieces
that are able to check me at the king
you got you have some more half open
files now that's true
trying to ruin the connector
wait what no what happened to the cube
yeah c4 queen shack b5
wait the king is getting yeah opposition
white's gonna have a mating attack like
king d6 white's king is safe
what is this
still theory
queen eight
this is beautiful
the cube has been destroyed yeah
the king on b6 is the safer of the two
kings now
oh probably won't see queen takes queens
move his king and hang his queen we're
going to see it oh he doesn't see that
that's crazy
so black's setting up for the next game
rick a bishop c8
he missed it black is up a rook and a
knight
for three points yeah but and also black
has a lot of half open files
and a lot of open rings too
both sides trying to lose on time man
your guys oh no bishop c6 oh no all of
your pieces
but white still has pawns
and the game has ended but nobody knows
how because we're behind
what's that something i lost on time i
guess is zero
did white lose on time
uh
yes
it was time and resign okay good game
that was entertaining yay great game
black one so i'm up three and a half one
and a half
sadly cool but you should but you're
still happy because the stafford one i
i'm happy and sad yeah
the stafford wins okay so this is right
team feingold up three and a half one
and a half
no my belt's going to go back so if i
win this game the match is decided yeah
then but then we'll we'll still finish
off
yeah
still got the arm wrestle too no
okay so we have
game this is game number six
and
let me see if uh we can get that better
be a big
belt bring it around here we go to get
the prize ready okay all right
eric fixes the the boards
okay so is it actually fixed let's look
this is another opening that i play this
is very similar to our game in st louis
it's too early to put it on yeah it is
too early yeah
the match is still ongoing
so my guy's white your guy's lights and
you play this with white then right well
i played this against you insane yeah i
remember i played a brilliant b5 ponzac
well you played some like cool d5 e5
idea i think you played terrible what
yeah you played terrible
game yeah you forced me in the end
that sounds fair
it was fair but also how did i play the
the pirates if i don't play it did you
trick me i yeah because you tried to
play kings india you think that's my
london i tricked you knight c3 before
okay
all right my team's up three and a half
one and a half eric needs this game
desperately
my guy's going all out
he's putting it in he's menacing
you're always rooting for your team but
my guy always plays your openings so
you're always that's true like my guy or
your guy is also kind of my guy
the way that karen is that's funny
because you're willing
yeah yeah that's strange how that works
this looks like a dragon door for now
without a6 yeah
more like a drag yeah
put it in h
h5 is really annoying to deal with
how does black not get mated
he can do it
man white has more time than he started
with
really i guess so yeah
he's been blizzard these moves are easy
to play just g4
coupons checkmate the king
i think the king's gonna be running
again and running and running
like forrest gump mm-hmm
okay box to move
two moves away from checkmating white
isn't g5 checked as me
it almost is g5 it's almost gonna be
made soon it's close
they're making more oh i don't know
about that move wait that's a good move
though is it is it oh because he has
that
yeah there's yeah he's got that
preserving the emote worthy
whoa um
so it's made in one
two three right
for one three for whites oh really oh
yeah there there there oh yeah i didn't
see that let's not say it too loudly
though
made in two
wait a minute wait he played it
how come your board's not updating okay
there we go yeah my guy played it
no king f4 and e3 nice and safe
there's three legal moves here that's
not too safe
well i didn't see e4 i didn't see it was
legal
that would have been best
but bishop d3 like attacked the king and
defended against that's right black smee
threats
it's unfortunate white has already
castled
yeah
because there could have been some
counseling
oh missing one
but making things
right queen e2 queen g2 queen g4 queenie
four queens
yeah i can't draw arrows but
oh now getting the last piece into the
attack knights on the rim are grim
though hey where's my belt
oh no my belt oh no my belt
if white wins this you've secured the
belt
if white wins
that's that's one of the mates gg
oh that game was close
we weren't sure who was going to win for
a long time
yeah well played to brigham
yeah sure yeah well yeah they waited to
play they've been waiting the whole
night
team feingold
raised the roof
you're only safe for entertaining you're
only saving grace this match was was
karen on your team drawing against the
2000 that's true yeah karen's mvp
vip
yeah let me see this belt you gotta show
it on the stream
we do we gotta show what it looks like
yeah it's fantastic
we'll go full video here
so this is a live stream
people can maybe see it
this is for youtube
this is how beautiful this is we won the
belt
i lost the belt
there is we were where we got four and a
half already
oh look at that i knew it now we might
need a little extension there that's
right what's that yes
so it's going to be uh kyojin
against you were the mvp for eric's team
yeah it fits around my neck thank you
for spinning yeah okay
it would fit you you can give it to uh
karen yeah karen would fit around karen
yeah
maybe yeah no for sure
yeah i'm like four times bigger than you
maybe someday it'll fit on
you i had to lose like 80 pounds so
maybe
and my deathbed will fit yeah what's
this is this this is oh this is where
the belt goes in
wow look at the carrying pouch
nice
wait wait please begin
okay we got e4 all right
all right who's my guy
your guy is
aiden aiden
i'm playing the black pieces playing
black they even played a6 before what
did they call this the century saint
george yeah
didn't uh karpov lose to tony
in 1980 in scara or something wow black
already may be winning a pawn
how good is your guy my guy's 1800 is
probably underrated blitz is probably
better oh my guy is uh
not 1800
like higher or lower i think he's lower
i'm not sure though
so my guys black this game
developing pieces isn't his thing taking
pauses this is aiden he plays in my
tournaments all the time on my stream
ooh
hmm let me check my guy nothing you can
say
oh yeah my guy is uh 1479. i'm only
chess
on
leachates man that's like what 300 on
chess.com yeah harsh it's
we try to make fun of chess when we can
we try yeah
but hey look at the position you know
he's got a lot of
more things developed
and more half open vials too more half
open files
that was my guy last time
that's true
okay so my guys went 2-0 with the staff
for one with white one with black
that's true actually yeah
how did that happen yeah my team is
winning with the stafford both sides
that's crazy
i mean part of your team is also
it's part of your team part of my team
and vice versa
yeah
my viewers are your viewers
i think like your channel is one of the
channels that has the most overlapping
viewers with mine
wow
tactics two pawns what else more half
open files
but here's the two bee shops but the the
rook is about to lift there we go
do you even lift bro do you even
brooklift bro that's even important to
know for the arm wrestling man that's
true actually i got i got to do some
rook lifting you know
yeah i'm so old and weak i can't even
rook lift oh yeah i just can't do it
well you just have to use some lighter
weight rooks that's right single
weighted pieces
oh that's not how you reflect right g3
that's he's making a battery on the
third rank
that's true my guy's playing faster than
your guy
but my guy has two bishops well he
played bishop e3
so
you said that he's like
but you do have more half open files
black has no open file shoes no terrible
terrible rooks
we have a bishop outpost
it's happening
so my team won the match already four
and a half one and a half we're trying
to see if he can make it a close match
when the last two make it close
if we win the last two and then i beat
you in arm wrestling then that's a did i
steal the belt maybe if you steal the
belt and run away with him i get to
chase you no
we'll see
so that looks like an outpost
oh it's about to be an outpost
and the c3 square
yeah but the bishop has that outpost
man your guy's not doing well on time
my guy's super fast i feel like you've
you've trained in to be never play f3
yeah you can used to go to our club a
lot in uh atlanta
california
and now we don't have the clubs i mean
it's everything changed
and eric was the one who started the
website
and you made our logo it's it's a full
circle yeah your logo and uh that's
pretty good
you
open your ears
let's see how many viewers are still
around for this oh karen's still in chat
along with stephen gray
let's see i can't i can't even find this
stream seventeen hundred eighty videos
let's go hey everybody there's like it's
the stream there's about a dozen viewers
in person too
okay so white's putting everything on
the third rank
h3 a3 coming
yeah you were hoping for eight puns on
the fourth and fifth rank last game i
mean it's possible for black this game
mm-hmm that's right
already two pawns on the fourth
cementing the knight on uh on c3 yay
thanks for the raid hey it's omid oh
mid-mail
yeah he's uh i met him in real life just
uh there's a lot
i thought the internet was real life
yeah well omit exists like in
different forms
real life online
he won a really nice game in the
national wow c4 is explosive wow
oh wow yeah this is explicit i don't
know
yeah wait what is right
man that was a good tactic
does it work though
we never know
the knight can't really attack the rook
but uh
there there's a yeah that's a put away
move yeah
can't say it too loud
yeah you're good i'm trying to be
soft-spoken here you guys got 26 seconds
left
we kinky
looks annoying and rook d8 and anything
so whichever rook moves the other rook
is pinned but that other that outpost on
a4
kind of like that bishop controlling a
lot of empty space at least my guy has
two bishops
uh-oh ninety-one
but it's hard to see night moves on the
back c5 yeah
wait
uh-oh oh no
white flag white flag
probably should take the rook instead of
flagging yeah yeah
it's hard to make moves like in real
life now i could take more time
all right do you want my fellas hey my
thing stopped your thing stopped yeah
look oh no
they didn't see the end of the game
did i fix it
okay that's the final position sorry
guys
white lost on time in this position
the first non-resignable position of the
game that's true
okay one final game
all right one day
of titans
winner takes all but not really the dgt
guy has his running shoes on
uno mas
go team feingold oh your team gets
prizes oh yeah that's right they get to
like book store stuff my team gets
sadness and sorrow yeah
go team feingold
man now karen gets nothing go go team
eric
i'm still gonna give my team merch i
have a lot of merch giveaways oh you do
yes all right fix my thing ah
that's your job my job is to sit here
and be pretty
okay
keeping pretty mm-hmm
there we go oh it's a bunkhouse it's a
bong clown they almost repeated always
repeat
slow motion replay
still theory
oh dude what color is my guy i forgot
your guy is a smaller guy he's white
okay yeah
king d4 winning king of the hill king d4
i'm not saying i don't i'm not sure that
black white is doing well now
bishop g5 it's almost getting mated here
but who's getting made bishop g5
with the skewer oh maybe yeah maybe i
don't know it's a move yeah i guess king
h6r stops everything
king f62 king f4 oh
what a move wow
wow
maiden one he did he find the move
he found the move
wow a perfect game
developing the knight wow
and now we black has the opposition the
victory celebration
man karen's like only half point for
your team do you ever jump up and down
like that
oh yeah that's what i do yeah
all right team feingold six and a half
one and a half
very suspicious result i feel
broken but that's okay yeah you get 102
in the staff bam and then to finish like
this that's right
opposition in the opening it's like the
game nakamura jeffrey shang
yeah
except not really